avec ses 131 mille habitants la
troisième circonscription de l'yonne est
la plus peuplée du département une
circonscription qui s'étend de joigny à
pont-sur-yonne en passant par sens et
brienon sur armançon une circonscription
détenue jusqu'à présent par la droite
marie louise fort l'actuel député ne
briguera pas un nouveau mandat
c'est donc clarisse quentin adjointe au
maire de sens qui portera les couleurs
de la droite et du centre
sa priorité l'emploi la réussite en
matière d'emploi c'est que les
demandeurs d'emploi soit informée des
offres disponibles sur le territoire et
c'est qu'aussi les formations
disponibles sur le territoire soit en
adéquation avec les besoins des
entreprises pour qu'elles puissent se
développer centrée sur les territoires
sans avoir besoin d'aller voir ailleurs
si les résultats qu'on a obtenus sur le
territoire que je souhaite porter au
niveau national pour une application
nationale
si la droite avait réalisé un bon score
dans cette circonscription en 2012
le front national et son candidat julien
odoul pourrait venir jouer les trouble
fête
moi je souhaite être le représentant de
marine le pen pour une opposition forte
patriotes et républicaine une opposition
aux politiques et des mânes et de macron
encore nos positions longues à
l'immigration massive une opposition au
matraquage fiscal une opposition aussi
aux compromissions avec le
fondamentalisme islamiste et une
opposition aussi pour lutter
véritablement contre le terrorisme qui
ne sera pas le cas avec ce gouvernement
invité surprise de cette élection la
république en marche
représenté par michel projet son
objectif donner une majorité au
gouvernement pour développer l'emploi
sur l'ensemble des territoires
quand on est rural on manque de services
publics dont elle sera amélioré
l'accessibilité aux services publics
ainsi que développement des petits
commerces locaux qui est aussi qui veut
leur permettront de vivre et au niveau
urbain ce sera de développer davantage
d'installations entreprises pour
favoriser l'emploi et le développement
économique parce qu'il ya un gros
potentiel entre secteurs là ça ça peut
passer notamment par le développement du
très haut débit
de son côté dominique bourg
candidat du parti socialiste tentera de
convaincre les électeurs sur le thème de
la réduction des inégalités
peu de personne cumule beaucoup de
richesses et que par contre on a
beaucoup de laissés pour compte et c'est
des situations qui deviennent
intolérables il ya la fiscalité qui
permet qu'un régulateur en la matière et
il ya la lutte contre la fraude et
l'évasion fiscale
ce quelque part des leviers qui
permettent d'agir dans ce domaine le
candidat socialiste trouvera face à lui
isabelle michaud candidate de la france
ont soumis nous aurons à coeur de nous
battre contre laval conneries à coeur de
défendre les services publics que macron
à l'intention de casser à coeur de
défendre aussi une transition écologique
en sortant du nucléaire en mettant du
bio dans les cantines de faire aussi en
sorte à ce que les agriculteurs de la
circonscription puissent travailler en
bio en agriculture biologique et être
aidé dans ce sens quel candidat
rassemblera les électeurs de gauche le
fn soeur flora t-il sur les résultats de
la présidentielle la droite
conservera-t-elle la circonscription
pour l'heure difficile d'établir des
pronostics
et on découvre ensemble les noms des dix
autres candidats ils sont en effet
quinze au total dans cette
circonscription a brigué les suffrages
des électeurs le 11 juin prochain